[Musique]
dans le débat sur france 24 consacrait à
ce que boris johnson considère comme la
mesure choc de sa politique migratoire
envoyer les migrants arrivés
illégalement dans son pays au rwanda le
premier avion décolle ce soir selon
londres 130 personnes était d'abord
prévu et s'était vu notifier leur
possible départ et pourtant les
critiques fusent d'abord celle des
défenseurs des droits humains de l'onu
de l'église anglicane et même de la
famille royale britannique
l'association care for calais a appelé
la justice à stopper ce projet cruelle
et barbare mais la justice britannique a
rejeté des recours de dernière minute
les contestations individuel lancé en
parallèle ont eu néanmoins pour effet de
réduire l'ampleur du projet alors
comment en est on arrivé là comment
boris johnson et son gouvernement
ont-ils imposer un tel projet quel est
l'accord passé entre le royaume-uni et
le rwanda quel est le sort réservé aux
migrants envoyé au rwanda cette
politique va-t-elle durer va-t-elle
faire des émules elle pose plus
largement la question de la gestion des
flux migratoires en europe notamment
londres expulsion vers le rwanda une
politique migratoire qui fait polémique
on en parle avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés jean claude
samui et bonsoir vous êtes vice
président d'amnesty international france
bienvenue dans le débat en face de vous
à maghama cool bonsoir rédactrice en
chef à france 24 est responsable du site
info un migrant nous avons avec nous en
direct de kigali au rwanda alain me
coralina porte parole adjoint du
gouvernement rwandais bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue
bonjour madame en studio à londres dès
ce match est un ancien ministre
travailliste des affaires européennes à
bonsoir à vous
vos soir vous pouvez tous bien sûr
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux sur le
hashtag et des bas france 24 avant de
démarrer ce débat eh bien on va d'abord
regarder ce sujet en image qui fait un
point justement sur cette menace que ma
exécution finalement boris johnson cette
politique migratoire cet accord entre le
rwanda et le royaume uni s'est donc
l'herbe aux niches on sait tout de suite
cet hôtel de kigali s'apprête à
accueillir le premier groupe de
demandeurs d'asile expulsés du royaume
uni en les envoyant au rwanda à 6000 km
au delà le gouvernement de boris johnson
entend ainsi dissuader les traversée
illégale de la manche c'est un point
essentiel de notre stratégie pour briser
le modèle économique de ces gens
épouvantable ces trafiquants qui font
commerce de la détresse les gens payent
souvent de l'or
depuis le début de l'année plus de dix
mille migrants ont traversé illégalement
la manche pour atteindre les côtes
britanniques porté par boris johnson la
mesure inscrite dans le plan immigration
du gouvernement a été validé par la
justice mais provoque un tollé en
grande-bretagne
les chefs de l'église anglicane dénonce
une politique immorale le prince charles
a lui jugé le projet consternant tout
comme de nombreuses organisations de
défense des droits donc on est en train
non seulement de se défausser d'une
façon odieuse et tout à fait inhumaine
mais d'envoyer vers un pays
qui ne respecte pas les droits de
l'homme c'est une sorte de refoulement
ce qui est tout à fait interdite pour
des personnes qui risquent une
persécution en vertu de son accord avec
kigali londres doit financer dans un
premier temps le dispositif à hauteur de
140 millions d'euros le rwanda précise
qu'il proposera à ces migrants la
possibilité de s'installer si des
personnes demandent l'asile au rwanda et
que leur demande est rejetée dans le
cadre du processus que nous avons mis en
place ici elles auront toujours la
possibilité de résider légalement au
rwanda
le rwanda où le gouvernement est
régulièrement accusé par des ong de
réprimer la liberté d'expression et
toutes opinions politiques et un pays où
la majorité de ces migrants n'ont aucune
attache à mort à macolin vous qui êtes
parti justement de ces observateurs de
france 24 il regardait bien cette info
migrants les informations sur les
migrants comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé finalement un tel accord est ce
que c'est vraiment la mesure choc de
boris johnson en termes de politique
migratoire mais c'est sûr que c'est une
mesure choc parce que
européenne pour l'instant c'est encore
inédit le but de cette mesure c'est de
repousser les migrants d'éviter ces
arrivées par la manche qui est pourtant
son record cette année dont d'ailleurs
on peut s'interroger sur l'efficacité de
la mesure puisqu'on en parle depuis des
mois les migrants de calais le savent
depuis des mois et on atteint un chiffre
record de dix mille traversée de dim
traversée de la manche depuis le début
d'année ce qui est bien plus que que
l'année dernière à la même époque donc
ce n'est pas dissuasif en tout cas pour
l'instant on l'instant ça ne l'est pas
nous sommes d'ailleurs nous même aller à
calais en reportage au lendemain de la
signature de cet accord et les étangs
d'avril ans exactement où est le 14
avril et donc les mille migrants
présents là bas était totalement
désespéré il n'y croyait pas il était
incrédule beaucoup nous ont dit c'est
terrible pour nous c'est encore pire que
ce qu'on pouvait penser on n'a aucun
horizon mais on va quand même y aller
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
continuer la route d'autres incrédule
disait on va quand même attendre de voir
ce qui va se passer mais on va quand
même continuer la route parce qu'ils ont
des attaches là bas parce qu'ils ont des
parce qu'ils ont un projet de vie là bas
beaucoup parlent anglais il avait il
avait des projets donc je pense que pour
le pour le mot choc oui ça qualifie bien
à quoi j'ai un peu de ses moyens choc
cruelle et barbare indice des
associations c'est exactement comme ça
que vous le qualifiez pour nous
messieurs international on ne peut pas
transiger avec le droit d'asile c'est le
dernier qui reste aux personnes qui sont
persécutés dans leur propre pays donc on
ne peut pas transiger avec ceux avec ce
droit d'asile les personnes qui sont
persécutés c'est tout ce droit d'asile
et codifié dans la convention de genève
et la convention de genève n'a rien à
voir les politiques migratoires n'y
avait de la compassion c'est un droit
qu'on a donnée aux personnes qui sont
persécutés dans le persécuté dans au
pays de trouver l'asile et une
protection chez nous donc on ne peut pas
revenir sur nos propres valeurs on peut
pas revenir sur nos propres engagements
comme le fait la grande bretagne
aujourd'hui délice mcshane bon vous êtes
du parti travailliste donc j'imagine que
vous êtes opposés à cette politique de
boris johnson mais mais lui boris
johnson dit que c'est pleinement
conforme au droit international et au
droit national et d'ailleurs pour
l'instant le juge est bien est d'accord
avec cette politique entraîne la remet
pas en cause
comme l'a dit madame sylvie bermann un
des grands diplomates la france
ambassadrice en chine en russie et en
angleterre au momo période de proxim qui
rencontrait
monsieur johnson plusieurs fois et dans
son livre elle est décrit comme un bolt
invétéré montrent un vrai j'ai jamais lu
une telle description d'un premier
ministre britannique pas une des grandes
diplomates du quai d'orsay donc mais le
problème on essaie avec
toute sa vie ne s'est pas la différence
au de la vérité c'est bon sauf pour les
jeux jodie technique ball également le
gouvernement à aa le pouvoir de faire ça
il faut pas aussi
rappelé que le danemark est aussi sur le
même pis le gouvernement socio
démocrates mais on va y revenir va venir
des élections
est ce que c'est une politique qui les
lie to me boris johnson
exactement cynique et sur pression
énorme une majorité de ces députés qui
ne sont pas des ministes donc ce pas
payer pour louis pour leurs salaires ont
voté pour qu'il part du leadership du
parti conservateur et le downing street
il est dosé crise permanent de survie et
donc il fait sortir ses petites gestes
comme ça c'est uniquement un peu d'air
oui moi je peux être aussi go avec les
immigrés que les partis de droite et
uicc et pour france marine le pen aurait
xml reste donc et on regarde à la fin
dix mille arrivait cette année et 9 ou
10 peut-être envoyer par avion au rwanda
et s'il veut il peut quitter leur hôtel
il sait pas aux prisons ils sont pas
regardées par les gardes armés et
recommencer le voyage vers l'intestin de
choix ccc l'angleterre c'est aussi un
défi pour toute l'europe notre
inhabilité de faire en sorte que les
pays qui qui expulse ces réfugiés ne
sont pas des pays ouvert qui traitement
pour des plus des sauterelles économique
marche pour que la population restent
chez eux à la mie câline d'art qu'est ce
qui la motive vraiment le rwanda a signé
cet accord avec le royaume uni est ce
que c'est un coup politique pour le
rwanda est ce que c'est une opportunité
économique
je dirais d'abord que le rwanda était
motivée à l'expérience
que le rwanda a dans ce domaine depuis
une décennie de trois décennies les
rwandais ont vécu ce genre de situation
comme réfugiés comme les grands et puis
l'on veut qu encore une fois c'est cette
situation quand les rangs des sceaux
venu au rwanda et quand on a accueilli
aujourd'hui plus de 130 mille réfugiés
sur le territoire 3d donc
partager le peu qu'on a partagé notre
territoire c'est quelque chose qu'on est
habitué à faire mais encore ma part oui
l espace
nous voyons depuis on est en train de
nous parler du cynisme on est en train
de nous parler de transiger avec le
droit d les droits des droits de l'homme
mais je pense que
plus important est de se poser la
question si on doit toujours continuer à
regarder les gens à mourir dans les
déserts les gens entre les trafics entre
les mains des trafiquants humains les
gens en train d'être transformée en
esclavage dans l'esclavagisme moderne
elle et moi yade est ce qu'on peut
pendant cinq six sept ans disant
continuer à regarder et croiser les bras
donc le rwanda est motivée par le fait
que aujourd'hui il faut sauver des vies
il faut
sauver ces gens des cm2 ces crimes vous
avez l'impression de les sauver l'ours
qu'effectivement parce que c'est ce que
disait monsieur jean-claude samui et
c'est en fait ça viole la convention de
genève la conférence de genève elle
proscrit le refoulement des demandeurs
d'asile vers un pays où les libertés
sont menacées on sait que le rwanda ce
n'est pas vraiment une démocratie
complaire au mondial vraiment des
associations qui se plaignent en tout
cas d'atteintes aux droits de l'homme
dans votre pays donc s'il ya une
violation de la convention de genève
cela mais cela aurait posé des problèmes
si l'accord qui a été conclu entre le
rwanda et le haut le britannique avait
interdit à ces associations ou à
n'importe qui d'aller vers les tribunaux
les cours et tribunaux cela a été fait
si le juge estime que
le programme peut continuer ce que d'un
autre côté il confirme que cet accord
nos villes aucun traité le vieux aucune
loi j'ai en tout c'est peut-être comme
ces raisons là dessus pourquoi est ce
que le juge britannique effectivement
lorsqu'il a été saisi par les
associations au final laisse boris
johnson mettre en place la politique
migratoire de son choix y compris
lorsqu'elle est si strict alors si j'ai
bien compris ils ont limité le nombre de
personnes qui sont qui ont quitté qui
vont quitter en tout cas le territoire
britannique parce que les autres
personnes sont procédure justement
ouvert un recours donc sur les croix
trente et une personnes qui devaient
quitter prive au démarrage mais
finalement il n'a que 7 qui qui
prendrait l'avion ce soir ou demain
matin la première heure mais dont il y
en a sept ça veut dire que le juge
laisse passer ce prêt est
passé mais quand on pense que ces gens
qui viennent d'irak qui viennent d'iran
qui viennent d'afghanistan ont subi les
pires atrocités dans leur propre pays
les persécutions dans leur propre pays
ont subi les pires atrocités tout au
long du parcours et n ont qu un seul
objectif c'est d'aller en angleterre
parce qu'ils y ont de la famille ou une
communauté une guest pour importante et
qu'on voit les refouler 6000 kilomètres
d'ans dans l'autre sens mais c'est c'est
le degré zéro de l'humanité enfin on
peut pas les gens ne sont pas des
marchandises quoi leur projet c'était de
rejoindre la famille est là plutôt que
de mettre en place des voies légales et
sûr pour que les gens puissent
bénéficier puissent faire valoir leurs
droits à la plagne protection
internationale on l'est on les renvoie
que me comme une simple marchandise 6000
kilomètres de leur but de le re de leur
famille de leur communauté à la mekkera
linda ou peut-être répondre justement à
ce qu'il vient de dire jean que de samui
et je suis désolé à écouter la personne
avec on est tenté de battre on dirait
qu'on envoie ces gens à la mort on
n'avons pas ces gens à la mort les
avants dans un pays sécurisé on les
envoie dans un pays oui c'est un pays
pauvre mais c'est un pays pauvre qui est
prêt à participer à une solution pour
résoudre ce problème problème de
migrants qui dure si longtemps alors que
ces organisations internationales alors
que ces gouvernements n'ont rien fait
aujourd'hui le rwanda et
le gouvernement anglais ils sont prêts à
essayer de nouvelles solutions ils sont
prêts à essayer de nouvelles façons de
faire pour résoudre le problème moi
j'accepte les critiques moi j'accepte
les débats on accepte même que les
dossiers soient
amenés devant les juges mais quand la
décision a été prise l'essai au moins
ceux qui sont prêts à essayer de
nouvelles choses allaient mettre en
pratique ne critique pas sans proposer
d'autres solutions jean-claude 5
milliards effectivement il ya peut-être
un déficit de propositions du côté du
royaume uni mais le royaume uni et est
signataire et a ratifié la convention de
genève le royaume uni doit proposer
l'asile aux personnes qui sont arrivées
sur le territoire et non pas les
renvoyer à 6000 km ceci étant il ya déjà
eu une expérience avec israël qui
refoulait des erythréens rwanda on a
documenté des faits que ces gens là
étaient affamés ne vivait pas dans de
bonnes conditions étaient parfois menacé
d'être renvoyé en erythrée où on sait
que c'est c'est la mort qui les
attendent donc les les conditions ne
sont pas réunies pour une vie digne au
rwanda et de toute façon l'angleterre ne
peut pas se déjuger l'angleterre ne peut
pas renoncer à ces à ses engagements
internationaux ils doivent donner
l'asile aux personnes qui qui qui ont
droit à un c'est encore une fois c'est
un droit et qui sont arrivés sur le
territoire dans les snacks chaîne
manifestement ce canton entend j'en fais
de samui et on pourrait se dire que
l'angleterre justement viole à la fois
la convention de genève le droit
international et pourtant dans votre
pays on peut mettre en place une telle
politique puisque même le juge
l'acceptent
pas la juge accepte ce que c'est fait
est légal ce la loi britannique je ne
déforme pas en voir continuer les
procédures et les juges ont aussi dit
que si 1 1
quelqu'un fait quelque chose de mes
shows belle et un des sept qui sont en
train d'arriver au sont déjà arrivés ils
peuvent revenir tout de suite en
angleterre donc on annule tollé et je
crois donc quelques mois on va voir que
cette pratique est un échec total bien
sûr le radar a obtenu à quelques livres
sterling pas mal ailier 120 millions de
livres dont ils ont appelé oui oui ouais
c'est important pour les pauvres
rwandaise mais je ne pense pas que
l'économie et l'avenir du rwanda
bout peut fonctionner on se tait les
oppose ce show jaunes de l'énorme co
pour chaque pays européen rob
israélienne où je sais pas d'où qui veut
renvoyer les réfugiés a pour être procès
c'est cela dit si la procédure continue
les les gens d'avoir accès à leur avocat
moi quand j'étais député j'avais un
tollé mills et paul ricoeur désir à
kafka destot des habituels de ba ma
ville ma circonscription et chaque
dossier des 2 300 pages traitées la
bresse bon par le ministre de
l'intérieur et les avocats et s'approche
des années qu elle le disait
quelques dizaines qui partent ce soir à
priori oui je pense que c'est la
ministre dire de cette façon ce n'est
qu'un premier vol qui en aura d'autres
qu'il faut mettre en place le principe
oui elle doit dire tout ça c'est
exactement à un moment qu à la france
possède ni submergé par les plombiers de
boulga aînés que sarkozy a donné une
prime de trois présidents à l'époque 300
euros à chaque bulgare qui veut rentrer
dans son pays
donc les romains aussi ils ont tous pris
la 3 100 euros pris le bus pour bucarest
est tout de suite acheté de vos billets
pour revenait en france donc c'est
toujours l'absurdité donc c'est un
michel monétique pour les politiciens
cyniques
l'accès hot j'ai ma part je vais faire
justement la jirs amara justement sur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un
petit peu amara comment comment ça se
passe parce qu'en fait on a l'impression
que le projet de loi de bruit johnson
distinguer bon réfugiés des mauvais
réfugiés donc il ya ceux qui arrivent
par procédure d'admission agréé par
l'état et puis il ya ceux qui arrivent
en situation irrégulière qui demandent
l'asile à la frontière donc ce sont ces
faux réfugiés entre guillemets qui sont
envoyées au rwanda il ya des
distinctions qui sont faites c'est ça
tout à fait donc là l'accord le plan en
fait concerne tous ceux qui arrivent il
également que ce soit il ya une
confusion entretenue par pendant un
moment on pensait que c'était uniquement
ceux arrivés par la manche en fait c'est
tous même ceux qui arrivent par la route
dans des camions donc tous ceux arrivés
par illégalement et uniquement les
hommes seuls on le sait on ne sait pas
exactement quels critères de sélection
il y aura mais on sait que ce seront des
hommes seuls donc pas de mineurs pas de
femme pas de famille qui seront envoyés
au rwanda et puis finalement critique at
elle a été un peu plus clair puisqu'elle
a dit que la grande majorité de ces
migrants demandeurs d'asile arrivés de
manière illégale ronda seraient
concernés par parleront de leur envoi et
le programme en fait prévoit que c'est
le rwanda lui même qui va instruire la
demande d'asile donné l'accord au nom
est proposé même à ceux qui seront
déboutés donc ça c'est quand même rare
dans un pays qui déboute de vin ou
quelqu'un pourrait déboutés du droit
d'asile mais quand même rester
légalement dans le pays ces journées et
et travailler donc en fait réellement on
leur propose de vivre d'avoir un projet
de vie au rwanda après l'instruction de
leurs demandes d'asile là bas il ne
pourrait jamais revenir en angleterre
c'est bien papa une externalisation de
l'instruction mais de toute la demande
de la prise en charge est ce que ça fait
partie quand même de ce qu'on peut
appeler une politique d'externalisation
des réfugiés comme ça peu ont totalement
plus particulier par exemple ou en
australie où ça puisse pratiquer en
israël c'est ça tellement c'est ça
rejoint cette idée là je fais tout à
fait moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est
quand même en matière d'asile n'y a pas
de d'arrivée irrégulière ainsi on
compare tous moyens on peut demander
arrivée raisin pays par tous moyens y
compris et rire est régulièrement pour
obtenir pour demain une demande d'asile
donc on ne faut pas qu'on se laisse
entraîner dans ce dans ce débat des
arrivées irrégulières ou d'arriver ici
illégal pour en matière d'asile toute
personne a le droit d'arriver sur un
territoire quel que soit le moyen pour
faire sa demande d'asile à l'ats me
currat linde ag lui d'ailleurs que 40%
la population rwandaise vit encore sous
le seuil de pauvreté il ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui chez vous
critique d'ailleurs cet accord en disant
que c'est déjà un pays extrêmement
densément peuplées que les terres sont
même insuffisante donc finalement
qu'est-ce qui sait les 120 millions de
livres sterling payé par la grande
bretagne qui je veux dire cet appât du
gain peut-être qui vous fait
signer ce type d'accord non je ne pense
pas que ce soit cet appât du gain
l'appât du gain qui fait qu'ils fassent
signer l'accord parce que on a déjà
accueilli des réfugiés alors que
aujourd'hui à ce moment là qu'on les
accueillir il n'y avait pas un
financement derrière comme je l'aï dit
au début aujourd'hui nous avons plus de
130 mille réfugiés sur le territoire
ondées et ceux qui critiquent
aujourd'hui ici à l'intérieur du pays où
alex tracts à l'extérieur n'ont jamais
critiqué quand on accueille plus de ces
cent mille réfugiés je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi ça devrait poser
des questions et les problèmes
manifestement il ya une différence
pardonnez moi parce que d'après ce que
j'ai lu le haut commissariat des nations
unies pour les réfugiés en fait il avait
effectivement il connaît cette espèce se
seront en dha qui héberge un certain
nombre de réfugiés mais là il dit très
clairement le hcr qu'il n'est pas du
tout favorable à la politique met en
place londres d'externaliser de cette
façon là dans un autre pays c'est à dire
de rejeter la responsabilité entière
finalement de ces réfugiés à un autre
pays c'est ça qui est surprenant quand
les gens sont en train de mourir comme
je le dis dans les déserts en traversant
le désert quand les gens sont en train
de se noyer quand les gens sont entrés
d'être exploité toutes ces organisations
ne font pas le même bruit qui sont
tentés de faire aujourd'hui
c'est surprenant
aujourd'hui les gens sont un peu d'ombré
depuis dix ans il n'y a pas de bruit
maintenant qu'on essaie de trouver une
autre solution on commence à crier alors
qu'on ne propose rien alors jean fau
samui évidemment réagi parce que
comme association évidemment qu'ils
réagissent toujours leurs soucis dans un
lieu que ce soit où que ce soit d'autres
ong on est vent debout contre la
politique contre le fait que l'union
européenne soit érigée en forteresse et
empêchent toutes les personnes de venir
enfin faire valoir leur droit à l'asile
sur son territoire donc on peut pas dire
qu'on ne fait rien on est vent debout on
s'insurge contre les mets et milliers de
morts en méditerranée on s'insurge
devant les murs qui s'érigent un petit
peu de partout il faut tout est fait
pour dissuader les gens à venir déposer
leur demande d'asile en union européenne
sur le territoire l'union européenne ou
en angleterre et nous nous sommes vent
debout quand c'est contre ces décisions
encore une fois le droit d'asile on peut
pas transiger avec le droit d'asile
c'est la protection des gens qui sont
persécutés chez elle donc ça c'est
vraiment notre notre travail quotidien
si je puis dire un couple c'est vrai que
ça met en question encore une fois la
politique européenne face à la politique
migratoire européenne qui n'existent pas
vraiment on a parlé de quotas il ya un
accord qui était passé avec la turquie
pour justement faire en sorte que la
turquie garde les réfugiés syriens donc
effectivement on se retrouve avec ce
type de proposition de boris johnson
phase peut-être un manque du côté
européen mais tout à fait alors déjà il
ya pas que la turquie il ya beaucoup de
pays qui cherchent à 100 externalisée
officiellement le traitement des
demandes d'asile qui cherchent à
contourner le droit d'asile on pense
notamment à l'accord ue turquie mais
aussi on peut penser à l'accord passé
entre l'italie en 2017 avec les
garde-côtes libyens qui n'ont cessé via
lieu de lire de les armes et de les
financer pour qu'il retienne et qu'ils
interceptent en mer les migrants qui
prennent lé bateau depuis la libye pour
arriver en italie on peut penser à
l'espagne avec le maroc aussi qu'il ya
eu lieu ils n'ont de le maroc d'argent
pour qu'il retienne les les migrants qui
arrivent en espagne on peut penser
également maintenant au danemark qui va
peut-être être le prochain sur sa liste
sur la liste a adopté une
politique
de la sorte à externaliser notamment
avec le rwanda les demandeurs d'asile
alors le danemark depuis longtemps mène
une politique anti migrants depuis 2019
et son arrivée au pouvoir la première
ministre social démocrate dit
franchement que son objectif et le zéro
demandeurs d'asile elle avait déjà
proposé même avant d'être au pouvoir en
2010 est une loi pourra passer des
accords avec les pays africains pour
créer des centres de tri de migrants
dans des pays africains aujourd'hui elle
est en passe de faire passer cette loi
notamment avec laurent dard et elle a
déjà notamment passer des fins et
organiser des renvoi d'afghans ou de
syriens vers l'afghanistan et la syrie
qu'elle considère comme sur même après
la rive donc à une sorte de tendance
vers cette externalisation des réfugiés
mais c'est atroce c'est atroce qui ce
qui se passe avec le danemark est le
renvoi de réfugiés syriens en syrie on
sait nous avons documenté un essai
international les atrocités qui sont
commises sur ces gens qui reviennent
dans leur pays des viols des tortures
des exécutions sommaires qui sont
considérés comme agent de l'étranger ils
sont considérés comme des traîtres au
régime de bachar donc dire dire que la
région de damas est sûr et qu'on peut
renvoyer des des réfugiés syriens mais
c'est une atrocité sans nom c'est une
indignité sans nom heureusement il n'y a
pas encore eu d'expulsion
de réaliser encore mais les gens n'ont
plus la protection au danemark les
réfugiés ainsi rien non plus la
protection danemark donc s'il ya un
mouvement de fond et nal de fond ou
remet en cause complètement le droit
d'asile et ça on peut pas on peut pas
tolérer ça c'est un tollé d'ailleurs ils
ont passé une première étape avec les
réfugiés syriens c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont
pas encore été renvoyés mais ces
personnes à qui on a retiré le titre de
séjour ou qui étaient légales qui sont
devenues illégales sont placés en
rétention sans date butoir de sortie de
la rétention elles ne peuvent pas être
expulsés parce que il n'y a pas encore
d'accord avec damas mais en tout cas
elle ne vivent plus leur vie est
suspendue donc le danemark ici on parle
que vous parliez tout à l'heure des
renvois de l'aide aux gardes côtes
libyens par l'italie mais même il ya vu
une tentative pour la france qui devait
y qu'il voulait offrir six bateaux garde
côtes libyens mais quand on sait ce qui
se passe dans les camps de migrants en
libye mais ccc c'est le degré zéro de
l'humanité quoi les gens se dé travail
forcé but alphonse et
prostitution forcée facile et ventes
d'esclaves qu'on avait vu il ya quelques
années sur la chaîne cnn donc c'est
intolérable on peut pas transiger on
peut pas négocier avec avec ces pays
allait me currat linda comment est-ce
que vous au rwanda vous garantissez à la
fois la sécurité de ces de ces réfugiés
qui vont arriver on a vu qu'ils allaient
être accueillis dans des hôtels c'est
bien cela et qu'ensuite ils auraient
peut-être la proposition de rester même
s'ils sont déboutés du droit d'asile on
n'a même pas le garantir aujourd'hui
parce que le territoire rwandais et déjà
sécurisé aujourd'hui je pense que les
temps ont changé s'insurger s'indigner
s'opposer ou s'offusquer ne suffit pas
aujourd'hui il faut proposer des
solutions concrètes est ce qu'on va
proposer à partir de demain dès que la
première personne sera arrivé ils seront
bien accueillis ils seront pas en prison
ils seront libres ils pourront
travailler ils pourront étudier ils vont
apprendre le kinyarwanda ils pourront se
faire soigner ils pourront voir des
avocats s'interrompre à la moto honda
mais vous ne faites pas juste ça pour la
beauté du geste
6 pourquoi pas on le fait aussi pour la
beauté des gestes comme je l'étais on le
fait parce que il faut sauver des vies
si les gens veulent un contrat de 120
millions de livres à la clé et
manifestement ça n'est que le début donc
145 millions d'euros ce qui est normal
chaque chose a un coût et on ne l'a pas
honte de le dire les herbes en outre été
d'avoir acheté ou vendu des êtres
humains bon c'est comme ça on ne peut
pas empêcher les gens de voir
aux deux prend des poses de telle ou
telle position l'essentiel est que ce
problème puisse trouver un jour une
solution est la première fois qu on va
essayer de l'autre côté il n'y a pas de
proposition donc s'insurger et
s'offusquer ne suffit pas s'il n'y a pas
de solution si vous n'avez pas décidé à
mettre en place laissez ceux qui ont des
idées de le faire au nord de nice
mcshane justement encore justement sur
boris johnson il va y avoir bientôt une
réunion d'ailleurs qui a lieu à kigali
me semble danser le sait très bientôt il
me semble assez sûr la réunion du
commonwealth dans lequel va dire on va
se joindre le prince charles qui lui
d'ailleurs a dit en tout cas en privé
qu'ils s'opposaient totalement à cette
a7 à cette mesure est-ce qu'on est dans
le cadre je dirais finalement de mesures
très politique d'un rapprochement
peut-être plus business entre le rwanda
et le royaume uni
oui je persiste et signe
quand vous parlez de notre cher premier
ministre le cynisme est toujours très
active et est présent mais regardons
l'australie là le parti travailliste
australien astra liens de la gauche
vient de remporter les élections ont
chassé boris thiolay l'australian scott
burns le premier ministre très droitiste
mais est ce que le nouveau gouvernement
de gauche va changer la politique de
refoulement 7d les australiens mais
place chaque réfugié au pas mal d'autres
bateaux longs moyer 1000km quelque part
dont la lotion pacifique dans ce petit
il est là isler les applications pour
pour avoir leurs effusions scali sont
considérés et traités je ne regrette
énormément
nous avons détruit leurs régimes de
lévis et d'une brégi mes chaussures
kadhafi mais on a ouvert les portes à
l'enfer mais plus le président sarkozy
et toute la france les militaires
français étaient très fiers que la
france libre et libre et l'ebit de idem
en syrie je n'aime pas le régime de
bachar al assad mais quand vous
détruisez une régime ne soit surpris que
tout le monde parte pas bien des
réfugiés qui sont maltraités mais aussi
énorme montréjeau qui nous regardent
chaque jour à la télé sur facebook sur
spotify et voit le bel vie chez nous par
rapport à l'enfer de leur vie en les
pays africains aux séries en libye donc
je le regrette énormément mais aussi il
faut être adulte parce que chaque fois
que ces excepté ces politiques surface
de seul gagnant c'est marine le pen eric
geboers plein matteo salvini en espagne
et tuent les doigts this de l'europe et
surtout chez nous pour aix était
directement lié à l'arrivée des trous
des gens venant de l'étranger pour des
raisons différentes donc on ne peut pas
être simplement angélique fed et des
condamnations faire des prêts chez
constitue l'ailé
les mets chauds sans avoir une position
politique et adultes comment mobiliser 7
fluxs immigrés des migrants réfugiés
tout confondu avec nos proches plus
intelligent et il simplement ces deux
questions barrera il faut accepter tout
le monde qui veut venir ah oui
moralement je suis avec cette position
politique est une politique raisonnable
alors vous aussi a élu sa passe pas 10
mcshea vous parlez de l'australie
justement c'est un pays qui a adopté ce
type de politique dont d'externaliser
s'est réfugié dans deux îles en
l'occurrence en papouasie nouvelle
guinée ça fait depuis les années 2000 en
fait qu'elle pratique cette politique
migratoire très strictes on va écouter
notre correspondant en australie
justement grégory place qui nous en
parlait il ya quelques instants
ce qu'il y à des fins de vous diront
bien sûr que oui ils feront remarquer
notamment qu'il n'y a quasiment plus
aucun migrant qui meurent en mer en
tentant de rejoindre christmas island
christmas island est une île qui se
trouve à quelques centaines de
kilomètres seulement de l'indonésie qui
s'ils voulaient est un petit peu le
lampes et tout ça australien la porte
d'entrée pour un certain nombre de
candidats à l'immigration dont ceux qui
défendent cette politique estime non
seulement qu'elle a permis de réduire
significativement les arrivées illégale
par bateau mais aussi de mettre un coup
au trafic des passeurs etc etc le revers
de la médaille bien sûr ce sont les
conditions des tensions dans ces centres
ouverts en 2013 à nauru et en papouasie
nouvelle guinée
conditions des tensions qui ont été
amenés à de multiples reprises critiqué
par des organisations internationales on
sait qu'il n'y a eu un nombre très
important de suicides des abus sexuels
des violences également infligé à ces
immigrés illégaux qui en fait dans la
plupart des cas ce sont des demandeurs
d'asile tout à fait légitime et qui
peuvent être retenu dans ses centres
pour une durée illimitée leur seule
assurance et on qu'ils ne pourront
jamais mettre les pieds en australie et
la personne qui a sans doute le mieux
incarner cette politique extrêmement
strictes et bien c'est l'ancien premier
ministre scott morrison il avait même
dans son but une sorte de petit trot
créé en forme de bateau avec écrit
dessus je les ai arrêté c'était un
souvenir de l'époque où il était au
ministère de l'immigration à la mie
câline il ya beaucoup de questions de
twittos tours justement de cette
problématique de la sécurité on vient
d'écouter notre correspondant en
australie finalement l'australie s'en
débarrasse en papouasie nouvelle guinée
et puis là il ne contrôle plus rien
comment encore une fois comment est-ce
qu à kigali on pourra être sûr que ces
réfugiés seront bien traités que ils ne
seront pas on leur imposera pas
certaines choses qui ne seront pas à
réprimer est ce que vous y aura des
accès peut-être à des observateurs
internationaux
quel sera le contrôle
à kigali au rwanda ces migrants ces
réfugiés seront libres ça c'est déjà la
première différence avec ce qui se passe
en australie ils sont pas emprisonnés
ils sont dans des hôtels ou murs de ce
point d'être traités quand ils seront
quelle est la situation de chaque
personne soit réfugié soit migrants à ce
moment là il devra aller cohabiter
s'intégrer parmi la population rwandaise
donc celui qui a ses papiers celui qui a
appris le kinyarwanda le français
l'anglais qui veut étudier ou qui veut
travailler il va pouvoir se mouvoir
comme il veut ça n'a rien à voir avec
ceux qui sont en australie qui sont
enfermés donc il faut tout simplement
respecter la loi la législation
rwandaise celui qui va commettre un
crime ça pour celui comme tout compte ou
en équipe fait et il sera défendu par
les avocats qui sont là et barrot ici
avec plusieurs avocats qui sont
compétents donc il n'ya pas se poser de
questions sur la sécurité ou sur la la
façon dont ils sont traités qui ont
entraîné pas vous ne pensez pas que
cette mesure soit immoral tout de même
parce qu'ils n'ont pas une fois très
clairement donc c'est assez tard c'est
un aller simple pour kigali de londres
qui allie avec peut-être c tandis que
disait bien ma collègue camara de
revenir de retourner au royaume uni où
c'est ce que disaient aussi de nice
mcshane et d'ailleurs la politique
australienne montre finalement pas
vraiment de gros succès puis elle a
coûté très cher à l'australie
morale si vous voulez il n'y a pas
quelque chose d' immoral parce que celui
qui arrive ici au rwanda il le choix
soit de rester ici au rwanda
puisque on le met dans un charter et
qu'il arrivera au rwanda comment est ce
qu'il aura le choix de quitter le rwanda
pardonnez moi mais je vous dis que le il
aura le choix de rester au rwanda soit
de choisir un autre pays si ce pays le 7
mai va pas l'accepter enfin il sera
coincé où il avait passé
ou de retourner dans son pays d'origine
je ne rapporte pas de rentrer c'est sur
ces problèmes c'est le problème est
justement janvie de ses moyens vous vous
répondre son pays d'origine si c'est
effectivement l'afghanistan le soudan du
sud en fin ou la syrie fa
si la finir c'est la fuit son pays
d'origine c'est parce qu'il y est
persécuté donc en aucune façon et au
vouloir retourner dans son pays
d'origine
faire le choix il faut que les choses
soient bien claires il faut que je sois
bien clair soit et restaurant da soit
ait choisi de retourner dans son pays
soit il choisit un autre pays 6 au pays
il accepte donc faut pas croire que les
gens sont envoyés ici pour être enfermé
au roanne non ça c'est pas correct
madame ça me paraît tout de même un
aller simple à maghama cool c'est tout à
fait un aller simple puisque le pays
d'origine n'est plus une option s'il
l'on fuit de base ils ne peuvent pas y
retourner d'ailleurs même quand on est
réfugié quand on devient réfugié dans un
pays on ne peut pas retourner dans son
pays d'origine c'est là c'est là c'est
le seul endroit où on peut plus aller
d'ailleurs parce qu on y craint des
persécutions et puis un tiers pays qui
pourraient les accepter justement toute
l'union européenne cherche à les
repousser je ne vois pas prévient il
pourrait trouver un tiers pays à part
leur honda qui pourrait les acceptez
donc les deux options de n'ont pas l'air
d'en être le problème la saison
parce que emmanuel macron va s'exprimer
en direct de roumanie et ses priorité au
direct